okay we're back live rise and shine time
for
science let's see what we've got
here this is a synthetic test
yeah this is not very
good okay let's figure out
why what is this thing
doing okay this one
worked hang on this worked look at this
this is
perfect yeah this is a perfect sweep
almost gam has got drift yeah
these I'm surprised it's actually found
something with this cuz there's a lot of
drift
logged we're just going to do a a short
morning session today on these
experiments um I'm not doing this whole
day
today I got stuff to do off stream but
we do a quick morning session on
experiments maybe I'll do another
afternoon session once they're done
we'll see
metric stats of Target
metric up to
cost
cost we'll do
I like this cuz this gives me consistent
plots for everything regardless of the
metric
so that'll help with that but then for
now let's take a look at
terrible um and then the parito
front enironment up
time that's really not bad
the thing is that I suspect that this
can be done
faster why is the data
so it's like so collapsed right
we definitely have to look at
this I this actually might be me having
overfit the synthetic task a little
bit this is crazy I have like multiple
accounts following me that I'm pretty
darn sure are Bots that have thousands
of followers
right the score is decent or
not 20 plus is considered Sol
so this is very decent like it doesn't
take very many
trials and get good per but
then the total time steps it kind of it
goes down here and it manages to
[Music]
find so these runs here actually are
like 30 million steps and then it finds
20 million step runs let's see the
cost yeah you see it takes the cost back
down which is really nice
this this seems like it's stuck and it
doesn't it's just it's too
conservative and this is after having
doubled all the search
ranges I think I'm penalizing it too
much for uncertainty
this yeah cuz this is not what you want
this to look like
really I mean it is possible that this
is just the optimal but I don't believe
that in sopia samples like eight mini
batches for p now that's very slow well
hold
on they do have batch size with a very
large batch size this actually could be
good and the 32 yeah that's a 32k mini
okay so that's actually maybe a decent
the parameter hold
on it's found a pretty high learning
rate gamma lock to the top has got to be
above pong doesn't have that high of a
gamma and then Lambda up there is also
yeah okay so this there's some
drift I also don't believe that they
can't find a better a lower update Epoch
solution
should and num M at 256 is going to slow
it down a fair bit as
well well I mean the good news is now we
can do these ablations on a real
environment let's take a look at
breakout for
comparison okay so this is find better
Solutions but this is running for way
too many steps for this
war it's got batch size locked
too probably not the best thing mini
batches is reasonable for the batch size
but it's like not explored this at
all I could believe the learning
rate gamma is maybe a little low I could
believe it same with
Lambda okay this is you know One update
I'm down with
that this is actually not these
parameters don't look
terrible um but clearly it's not
exploring
sufficiently well the cost is actually
pretty low here
though well in a th000 should be able to
it should be a to solve in about
12200 and the Pito front is pretty messy
but we know breakout is not a um bre has
a lot of sample
variation I think what we're going to do
here
is let's just
what or update
EPO I know this one updated I think I
might have changed
configuration just put this P
configuration and to break
out this could potentially be a little
bit better this is not going to
magically solve everything we still have
some tweaks to make uh the only thing we
need to change
is this is going to be from I think 2
E8 to 1 E9
and with a mean
steps yeah so this should be fine right
here
okay so now let's let's go back to pong
for a
second this this solves and solves fast
but I think that
the the cost isn't
there it is correctly pushing towards
lower
exploring this is very few M's to have a
lot of update
Epoch and then these parameters seem off
oversampling it's over
sampling so it's either over sampling
around a single Pito front or the trust
region around the parameters is too
conservative
we have two ter terms to our loss I mean
our acquisition
function why did I make the first term
conservative
I made the first term conservative so
that you sample the first term being
conservative tells you to make updates
evenly along the paredo
front wherever you are confident that
your update will be
good the second
term tells
you that you should make the highest
performing update in which you're
confident so I guess technically you
have two confidence terms so you get
confidence
locally I'm going to just try this
locally and then I think I'm going to go
uh I think that's going to just be it
just a short little morning stream for
launching new experiments and then maybe
I'll check back in throughout the day
because we're kind of in that stage of
of stuff at the moment right where it's
like we just have to check in on on
various
experiments I stream
offline oh no we're good oh hey YouTube
folks this is me checking in on our
carbs experiments from last night hyper
pram sweep experiments uh we're very
very close to having an amazing hyper
pram sweep Al alith for RL they're just
a few small quirks to fix with it I
really I've mostly redesigned carbs
which is this MB AI
algorithm
um I've mostly redesigned
it actually maybe I'll go over that out
loud because that'll be fun and maybe
I'll catch something that I
change so the change I want to make
is non is to remove the
conservative down from this oh there's
also this exploration bias term that's a
little
screwy so we'll have to look at that as
well
okay so let me go through the changes
that I made
here this is carbs we'll go to paper
review mode
this a year two years ago is and when I
saw this it was a huge deal because they
essentially they solved proen which is a
pretty good RL Benchmark uh with the
simplest standard algorithm that
everyone uses just tuning hyper
parameters so basically you don't need
to do any of the fancy algorithmic stuff
we were doing all you need to do is tune
hyper
parameters now this is a pretty
complicated
algorithm it involves three different
Gan
processes a local probabilistic waiting
function and then a clamped acquisition
function based on a parito
frontier and a few other things as well
so the thing that I did here is I
started digging through the code and I
noticed that the way that they were
normalizing hyper parameters uh they
really weren't normalizing the hyper
parameters correctly so it was pretty
hard to search over hyperparameter space
it was very unintuitive to configure so
I fixed that and it looked like it just
it did better so then I thought okay
what else might be weird in here so I
started really digging into the map
and the first thing I noticed was this
function um what this function does is
when is a I should explain a little
about how carbs works so what carbs is
going to do is it's going to look at
your paredo points Paro points are
hyperparameters that uh obtain the
highest score for the amount of time
that the training takes to run so a Paro
Point means that you cannot find a
better run in the sense that it is going
to be both higher score and faster to
train and the set of parito points is
called the parito front you kind of can
draw a curve through uh that set of
points and how much time you have to
spend to get a specific
score so what this thing does is it says
that uh when you sample a new point so
you're trying to run a new experiment
you grab a point from the parito front
and then you uh you expand around that
normally so you take a normal random
sample around this Paro
point but then what they do on top of
this is they down weight points that are
far from the parito sample so they have
this probabilistic function that
prevents you from going too far away
from your parito
points that seems kind of weird to me
because that's kind of just biasing you
towards running the same experiments
that you already have and it's doing
this in a very unintuitive way so I just
got rid of this
thing um and I handled this you know I
handle this in a different
way they have three different gaussian
processes that they use these are
learned models that are trained uh as
you run your
experiments they've got gpy which takes
the hyper parameters that you've run so
for all the different experiments you've
run and it predicts the score based on
hyperparameters so Maps hyper parameters
to score there's GPC which Maps hyper
parameters to cost so how long does an
experiment take there two different
models one to predict how good hyper
parameters are and one to predict how
long that they're going to take to
run and finally there's GP PF which
predicts the Optimal Performance
according to cost so all that this does
it takes in Paro points and says how
good they are so this is drawing the
Paro front this is telling you for a
specific cost how well can you do
then they have this acquisition
function and uh what this acquisition
function says is if we
sample some new hyper
parameters and then we use this uh if we
use these ging processes we can estimate
what we think that the best you can do
for the CL for that cost is so we
estimate the cost of the sample and we
estimate what the best that we think we
can do is and then uh this ISS how much
better do you think you can do than we
currently think that the best is it's a
little bit of a weird formulation I
tried replacing this with uh how good is
this point and it didn't work as well so
this tries to measure uh the expected
improvement over the current expected
maximum Improvement these things kind of
are fighting a little bit um but it
seems like this one works
I got rid of pearch here uh they do a
few other things though
so there's this major detail where they
do acquisition function
clamping and the way that they do this
uh is they try to they try to push you
towards higher cost Solutions which
really doesn't make any sense you kind
of don't want to go to high cost
Solutions you want to go to high
performance solutions regardless of
their cost the way that they do this
anyways is they replace uh they replace
this
estimate with the max of this estimate
and a randomly sampled Point
logarithmically throughout the Paro
Frontier so basically they can possibly
sample a higher cost point that could do
better than your current point and this
will increase the max term so this has
the effect of down weting samples that
are low cost this is a really inelegant
way of doing this uh so what I is I
replaced this thing which biases you
towards high cost with a multiplicative
term that is just your predicted
absolute performance so you bias towards
High absolute scoring Solutions
regardless of their
cost I also replaced a bunch of their
normalization stuff um they were doing a
bunch of like rejection filtering on
samples that could occasionally even
cause the algorithm to crash I replaced
that stuff with just clipping to within
a good search range um and the nice
thing about this absolute cost thing
that I included is that uh it's a
conservative estimate of absolute
performance so you take your prediction
of what absolute performances and you're
going to subtract the variance of that
prediction so if you're uncertain about
a prediction it gets down
weed and this kind of does the same
thing as this where here you're down
weting solutions that are far from
parito points we're doing something
smarter which is we're down weting uh
points that you're not confident about
the outcome of them now the problem that
we're having here is that the it's
possible for the model to collapse and
really only go towards points it's very
confident about which is what seems to
be happening here where it's just not
exploring at all around you know a
specific decent solution once it finds
it so I think that the confidence bound
is good but it's currently it's too
heavy you want to be penalized for doing
stuff you're not confident in but you
don't want to be you don't want to be so
heavily penalized that you only ever
explore the exact space of your
solution there's one other thing in here
that I don't quite understand and they
actually don't even
include in here which is this
exploration
bonus what is this exploration
bonus is it any good
so this actually should be
exploring quite a lot
cuz they are they have an Epsilon they
have a pretty heavy Epsilon in
there so I must really be uh clamping
this too
does and uh we'll see if this makes a
substantial
difference you're not going to be able
to tell for a while because
um you're not going to be able to tell
for a little while here though because
uh the first several samples are
random okay well it's Sunday I've got
other stuff to do today I will probably
check back periodically they're going to
be like little random short streams
whenever I do experimental analysis here
cuz these don't take very long to run
this will be done in like an hour or
two uh I'm going to probably go get some
breakfast do a couple things and then
check back
in for the couple folks on YouTube all
my stuff's on puffer doai start the
GitHub helps me out a ton you can join
our Discord there like 900 people in
here building all sorts of awesome RL
stuff and you can follow me on there's
some custom articles on here as well uh
RL tutorials blogs stuff like that thank
you and see you later bye